il faut le commander c'est pas la photo
de hitler qui est là et encore je
reviens sur ce que me dit gilles verdez
hitler on le voit partout sur toutes les
chaînes toutes les chaînes et d'histoire
quand vous regardez comme netflix est à
vous regarder ni gloire quand whitehorse
et douala et dans des positions qui sont
des positions avantageuses
maintenant comme ça le bras levé devant
des milliers de supporters comme un
public en un forum romain avec tous les
bons là et au moins il est expliqué les
bénéfices seront versés
c'est mon père qui a obtenu ces à la
fondation auschwitz-birkenau
les deux historiens qui ont fait le
travail qu'il faut citer florent
braillard inde rev andréas wehrling qui
est l allemand ont fait un travail
remarquable
ce livre ne peut faire que du bien parce
que par les cliques marquis il est lui
c'est à dire les universitaires et les
professeurs qui vont véhiculer l'esprit
critique à l'heure à leurs élèves alors
alexis vous êtes professeur d'histoire
aussi alexis corbière pas seulement
députés et pour vous vous êtes contre la
publication de cet ouvrage même avec les
annotations critique ouais c'est à dire
que j'ai entendu les arguments
le but ce parent et insee pour lutter
contre l'extrême droite faudrait faire
lire ce livre
ben c'est raté à 100 euros ça va pas
s'adresser à tout le monde
ces extrêmes chez nous même sabot je
vais y revenir si vous voulez mais pour
lutter contre le nazisme il faudrait
faire lire ce livre est quand même si
vous voulez pour l'ex sur l'extrême
gauche je trouve ça bizarre de votre
part comme été signé entre les choses
mais pour lutter contre les
totalitarismes ce qu'apple contre liens
solides entre les versions euros c'est
une élite qui va se le payer donc c'est
raté donc pour le choix alors vous
considérez que soit vous considérez que
c'est que les plus riches qui peuvent se
payer l'antidote contre les
totalitarismes
ou alors faut faire un travail populaire
donc cet argument il ne tient pas rue le
travail et populaire est fait par les
éleveurs les universitaires et les
allées alors les deux éléments les
universitaires ceux qui sont des
spécialistes des totalitarismes et
l'allemagne lise l'allemand ont déjà lu
mein kampf le livre interdit donc ça
c'est pas vrai ça n'existe pas le
travail et même ce travail existent déjà
pour cent lors on peut s'acheter
déjà l'équivalent 10 ou 15 euros non
mais moi je n'ai pas encore lu si vous
lui avec on apprend des milliers de
choses même moi qui connaît bien le
sujet on apprend des mineurs mais le
suédois pour un universités c'est
vraiment je le dis d'accord serment si
un trésor un trésor à 10 ans mais
j'espère que le travail ne s'adresse pas
seulement aux fils de serge et béate
klarsfeld
je ne vous ai tué 17 clairet là dessus
le débat est si sexy je pense votre
argument et je peux l'entendre
aujourd'hui un racing qui se développe
faut lutter conte faut des outils
pédagogiques pour le faire je dis que ce
livre n'est pas l'outil pédagogique en
question c'est pas vrai c'est le crew
alors pour le prix le free wheels le
volume et ses îles et réfléchissons à
des outils beaucoup plus efficace moi ce
que je crains c'est pour régler qui ne
prend pas les gens mais je vais vous
dire pardon je t'ai j'aimerais terminer
mon raisonnement c'est qu'il va y avoir
malgré tout une facilité édité s'est
diffusée il y aura un effet malgré tout
mais le livre à de pardon je suis permis
de signer un chrono de ma phrase
géraldine nadine le livre est dite
depuis 1979 où il est né l'argent vous
savez et publiant vous savez avec un
avertissement de huit pages j'ai compris
moi ce que je trouve c'est que on tolère
parfois une forme d'antisémitisme
mondain les gens qui ont de l'argent
moi je m'étais mis en colère ya pas
longtemps contre il ya un écrivain qui
s'appelle louis ferdinand céline a écrit
des livres le mile au voyage au bout de
la nuit puis aussi des livres
dégueulasse on trie ses missions et un
éditeur chez gallimard grands éditeurs
jeu les coûts soupçonne pas d'être
antisémite et quand même dernièrement a
tenu à rééditer ses livres moi je dis
est alors bien sûr on m'a dit c'est
livre chère luxueux mais on tolère une
forme les gens qui ont de l'argent mais
ces emplois les moyens parce que
soi-disant les gens qui ont de l'argent
et ils sont moins bêtes que les gens du
peuple et ils sont plus immunisée contre
les idées antisémites et moi je n'aime
pas cela et je vais vous dire il y aura
un effet malgré tout pas chez tout le
monde mais un petit effet d'aubaine de
s'acheter dans une édition luxueuse de
lire des saloperies antisémites et moi
je ne vois pas ça d'un bon oeil parce
que je trouve que c'est pas bien j'ai
acheté mais ils peuvent déjà l'acheter
mais ce qui sera dit gilles offrir
la collection merci avec la couverture
du faux l'heure en plus cela kaunas et
ouverture d accord c des éditions
souvent assez dégueulasse juste ils sont
pas très bien lisible de s'imprimer sur
son imprimante monsieur klarsfeld
s'imprimer à la maison sur une
imprimante mein kampf c'est pas la même
chose que d'avoir un joli livre merlier
et je pense qu'on peut mieux faire pour
lutter contre les totalitarismes alexis
je rejoins votre idée sur les 100 euros
est ce qu'il aurait pas été possible je
sais pas je vous pose la question de
faire une édition avec les annotations
critique qui soit équivalent lire à part
les universitaires moi qui m'intéresse
franchement le livre d'abord il est
ennuyeux s'il n'y a rien de personnel il
a il dit rien de personnel sur lui-même
ce sont des sortes de darwinisme naturel
qu'il transpose à la société avec les
races et tous à vouloir céder l'objet
sans même l'ouvrir personnes ils vont
racheter ses seins et certains dont moi
qui connaît bien le sujet qui
m'intéresse c'est à dire c'est comme
c'est pas moi quelqu'un qui connaît bien
tintin et milou alors il est très
content d'avoir un truc sur tintin et
milou
bon c'est un peu la même chose je
connais bien l'histoire c'est à dire
chaque chose me rappelle quelque chose
que j'ai déjà lu et tout ça même moi
j'ai trouvé ça ennuyeux mais en tout par
son texte mais enrichissant par les
gains par les critiques